اربع سنوات غابت فيها الفنانه عبله كامل
عن جمهوريها في مصر والوطن العربي كان اخر
ظهور تلفزيون لها في الجزء الخامس من
مسلسل سلسال الدم اما خارج الشاشه فابتعدت
كليا على التواجد في اي مناسبه فنيه مع
الحفاظ على عادتها في عدم ظهور باي لقاء
تلفزيوني او صحفي الدكتور اشرف زكي نقيب
المهن تمثيليه قال ان عبله كامل تمر بحاله
حزن شديده بعد وفاه صديقه المقربه لها
خارج الوسط الفني الفنان القدير التي قدمت
اكثر من 100 عمل في الدراما والسينما
والمسرح طلبت حتى تاجيل تكريمها في الدوره
الاولى لمهرجان القاهره للدراما التي
انطلقت في سبتمبر الماضيه وذلك بسبب عدم
قدرتها واستعدادها للظهور في الوقت الحالي
من غير المعروف ما اذا كانت عبله كامل
ستظهر قريبا على الشاشه لكن ما يهم الان
هو ان تكون بصحه جيده وتعود لترسم البسمه
على الوجود من جديد
[موسيقى]
الكثير من اساطير الكوميديا الذين طالما
اضحكون من قلوبنا نكتشف لاحقا صناعهم مع
الاكتئاب وكان خيطا رفيعا هناك يفصل ما
بين الضحك والماساه ايقونه الكوميديا
جنكري هضم معركه شرسه مع الاكتئاب سنوات
يقول انه تغلب على المرض بالروحانيه وتجنب
المشروبات الكحليه وتعاطي المخدرات
احد ابرز الوجوه في هوليود ومن رواد
الكتابه والاخراج الكوميدي عانى من
الاكتئاب لثلاثه عقود ووظف الفكاهه في
معظم اعماله كمحاوله
للتغلبيه
الكاتب والممثل الكوميدي الامريكي تعيش مع
الاكتئاب لاربعين عاما يقول ان الاعراض
ظهرت عليه عندما كان في السادسه من عمره
ايضا اصيب الكوميديا الامريكي المخضرم
لاري ديفيد بالاكتئاب في السبعينيات
ووقتها لم يكن لديه من مال ما يكفي
الاستشاره طبيب لكن على عكسيه تغلب على
الازمه مبكرا مع دخوله عالم ستاند اب
كوميدي
على فكره يعني من وقع هذه الحادثه سامعه
في مصطلح سمايلنج ديبريشن الاكتئاب
المبتسم
في ناس ما يعرفوها على فكره تخيل انه غريب
انه هو اكتئاب انه انت بتكوني حاله مبتسمه
والسعاده ظاهره عليك لكن بتعاني من اكتئاب
شديد جدا هذا المصطلح هو في علم النفس لا
من يعاني من اعراض اكتئابي مثلا
وبيخفوا وراء حياتهم ناجحه وعلاقاتهم
الاجتماعيه يعانون في ذات الوقت من اعراض
الدراسات يعني الدراسات النفسيه تقول بسبب
طابع حياتهم وانا ما طول الذي يبدو طبيعيه
اشخاص الذين يعانون من الاكتئاب المبتسم
يتلقى العلاج لازم لحالته
قدام الناس المجتمعين
وتخيلي انه اسباب الاكتئاب المبتسم يعني
مثلا بتكون مرور بمحنه كانفصال مثلا او
فقت وظيفه بتعرضوا الانتقاد في الحياه
ويقال كمان انه الرجال يتعرضون لهذا
الانتقادات بسرعه اكبر من النساء يعني
تخيلوا هم الرجال اكثر من النساء يمكرون
هذه الحاله ما بحبوا يطلعوا بموقف او
بصوره ضعيفه قدام الناس همم ضعف الخوف
والسبب الابرص في وقتنا الحالي ربما هي
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بحسب الدراسات
الاكتئاب المبتسم هي بتمنع كمان الاشخاص
من المشاركه ملاحظاتهم سيئه لالعالم
والتزام فقط بنشر الاحظات السعيده
المشاعر وهذا بيعطي مساحه طبعا لنمو
الاكتئاب السعيد
هو فعلا يعني هو الموضوع يعني مش معترف
فيه بس خطير جدا بس تخيلي كمان دائما
اتعس العالم هم المبنى نعم طبعا بس كثير
منهم قصص تاريخيه لكوميديين قادرين على
اضحك الناس ورسم البسمه على شفاههم وهم لا
يستطيع احد ان يسعد به بجراح قلوب الناس
اداويها